hi I'm Marc Horowitz from Yale School of
Medicine in HHMI and I want to tell you
a story about a discovery that has led
to our really wonderful
what's now 15 to 20 year experience of
experimentation that followed this
discovery was really somewhat
serendipitous and I think there was a
lot of luck involved
it was helped enormous ly by two
wonderful collaborators who have
remained very close friends and constant
contacts Ming Chang who's now in Taiwan
and aurash hartal who's now in Martin's
read and so I'll just tell you the story
as it occurred so the story is about
information transfer in the cell as we
know DNA is transcribed into RNA is in
turn translated into protein and the the
step that's involved here is the final
step of information transfer namely that
of protein folding so we know about
machines that carry out transcription
and translation and have very fine
molecular details to those reactions for
some years now increasingly fine but
protein folding has remained somewhat
mysterious and it's really only during
the last decade or two that we've really
started to gain some understanding about
how this works in cells so for those
unfamiliar I just point out that
proteins are composed of 20 different
amino acids and these strings of amino
acids ultimately fold into
characteristic 3-dimensional structures
they carry out biological activities for
example they could be enzymes
cytoskeleton hormones hemoglobin
channels receptors what-have-you
proteins are major effectors in the cell
and so their proper folding is crucial
to them being biologically active
because when they're as effectively
strands of spaghetti leaving a ribosome
they don't necessarily have any
biological activity at that
they have to be folded correctly in
order to be active and so the granddaddy
experiment of protein folding that I
heard about when I was an undergraduate
at Brown University in 1972 I was
carried out by Christian anfinsen in
fact in the late 50s he received his
Nobel Prize Oh Bell Prize for this work
in 1972 a really astonishing experiment
where he started with an enzyme
ribonuclease a hundred odd amino acids
with four disulfide bonds and unfolded
that protein by treating it with
denature and urea and reductant
mercaptoethanol that produced
essentially a random coil version of the
protein and he asked when whether when
he really removed the urea and reductant
whether the protein could find its way
back on its own in a test tube to the
native active form and astonishingly it
did so so this proved that a polypeptide
chain contains all of the information
for folding into the unique native
structure in its primary amino acid
sequence structure he also presumed that
in fact this native state would lie at
an energetic minimum and so this
astonishing experiment led people to
believe that perhaps inside cells
proteins also fold spontaneously but
increasingly there were instances where
that didn't really happen both in a test
tube where many proteins could also not
be spontaneously refolded as in the
antonsen experiment with ribonuclease
but inside cells when the biotech
industry began to express mammalian
proteins in e.coli for example they
often saw these terrible looking
aggregates with no biological activity
and failed to recover their favorite
proteins in a native active form in this
again one saw as in the test tube a miss
folded aggregated inclusion body as it
were and so this suggested that
something more might be required in the
cell to
deal with these so-called what would be
kinetic problems of folding where
proteins simply get it wrong and go off
pathway and miss fold and aggregate and
so we never thought we would have
anything to do with this but we were
busy in the late 80s studying
mitochondrial protein import so it turns
out that most of the proteins of
mitochondria are encoded in the nuclear
genome the messages for these proteins
are then translated on cytosolic poly
gravis ohms and an n-terminal targeting
peptide in these proteins directs them
to mitochondria and they're then
imported through the mitochondrial
membranes and that targeting peptide is
then clipped and the mature sized
protein then has to fold into its
biologically active form well an
important experiment was carried out in
1986 by Gottfried Schatz and his
co-workers that showed that an unfolded
that a protein had to be unfolded in
order to transit the mitochondrial
membranes
he used dihydrofolate reductase as a
substrate in these experiments showing
that if you lock dhfr into its native
state by adding the ligand methotrexate
the protein couldn't go through the
membranes whereas if you now removed
methotrexate or denatured the protein it
would go through the membranes so the
question that arose to us as we were
studying mitochondrial protein import
was do proteins upon reaching the
mitochondrial matrix space refold
spontaneously to their active form as
might be suggested by the ants in
experiments or could there be a
machinery that was required to assist
the protein to reach its native active
form and so we were in a position to
actually test this because we had a bank
of temperature sensitive lethal yeast
mutants that contained a galactose
regulated version of a mitochondrial
protein ornithine transcarbamylase a
human protein
that we had shown in yeast already could
be expressed and would go to faithfully
to its mitochondria have it signal
peptide cleaved and become biologically
active and make OTC enzymatic activity
and so our screen was basically to start
with temperature sensitive lethal yeast
mutants the idea being from Schatz and
others in the field that if you can't
make new mitochondrial proteins in new
mitochondria the cell basically stops
its growth and ultimately is it's a
lethal so we started with the Bank of
lethal mutants program to express
mitochondrial OTC behind a gal operon
promoter and we proceeded to test each
mutant individually for the ability to
make OTC activity after shift to
non-permissive temperature and shift
into galactose to turn on OTC expression
under non-permissive conditions we then
analyzed OTC activity if it wasn't
present we would then western blot the
particular mutant after shift to 37
degrees an induction of OTC to see what
the fate of the OTC subunit was was at
present as a mature sized protein or was
it still a precursor that hadn't been
recognized by mitochondria and so our
idea was to dissect the mitochondrial
import pathway well as we were asking
this question about refolding inside the
mitochondrial matrix we knew what we
would be looking for in the form of a
mutant that affects refolding in the
mitochondrial matrix space we would have
mature sized OTC subunits because their
signal peptide would be cleaved and
they'd be inside the matrix space but we
would have no enzymatic activity because
they would have failed to correctly fold
and in the case of OTC trimer eyes into
the active form of the enzyme so we
started to look through our bank of
mutants and to our astonishment almost
right away having asked this question we
found a mutant in which exactly that
happens so OTC was our initial reporter
enzyme and what we found was that OTC
subunits entered they reached their
mature size and then there was no
biological activity at
all so this astonished us it seemed like
heresy to have a result like this so we
thought AHA we'd better start to look at
endogenous yeast proteins and see what
is happening to them so we looked at
this particular protein the f1 beta
subunit ATPase of the f1 ATPase and we
found that in fact in similarly this
beta subunit had failed to assemble into
the this stock like structure and the
subunits themselves look like they had
Mis folded in the mitochondrial matrix
space we were in a bit of a quandary
because again it seemed like heresy and
we couldn't really feel comfortable
about the data at hand and we were sort
of pondering what proteins to look at
next
when thankfully the phone rang and it
was over Cardinal and Walter Newport
calling from Munich to say why don't we
understand that you guys have some
mutants that of yeast that affect
mitochondrial protein import and we
would love to get together with you and
perhaps help on some of the biochemistry
of those mutants if you'd have some
interest so at that point in history my
lab had four people in it and we weren't
very well versed at fractionating yeast
mitochondria whereas these were world's
experts so we were just delighted to
interact and I went to Munich the next
week and presented some of the better
described mutants that we had that
affected mitochondrial signal peptide
processing but I also at the end of my
talk described this particular mutant
and Walter and Ulrich were somewhat
worried that what was happening in this
mutant was that proteins were coming in
through this contact site but weren't
getting entirely into the mitochondrial
matrix that they were poking their
n-terminal signal peptides in and the
signals were being cleaved but then the
proteins weren't entirely entering and
of course they wouldn't fold if they
couldn't enter through
membranes and so I said well I'd be
absolutely delighted to send you the
mutant and you can make mitochondria I
am sure from this mutant very
effectively and analyzed to see what's
going on and and in fact as soon as I
got back I sent the mutant to Munich and
two weeks later
Ulrich called up to say excitedly you're
right the proteins are entirely in the
mitochondrial matrix I can add exogenous
protease and it doesn't touch them so it
seems like they have gone into the
matrix space and they have failed to
fold correctly so this was a really
wonderful time where there was a lot of
back and forth with Ulrich and I
crossing the Atlantic to visit each
other and discuss the phenotype of this
mutant this is us together at his
parents house here's his lovely wife
Monica who is a biochemist herself and
has worked some on the Gro al system as
well in recent times the chaperonin of
bacteria and maybe this is her telling
us how this is all going to work out but
in any case we carried out together a
set of experiments on a number of
mitochondrial matrix proteins to see
what was happening to them and one of
the most exciting results came with this
particular protein the risky iron-sulfur
protein so this is a protein that is
imported to the matrix space and has to
be cleaved twice as a monomer before it
enters the inner mitochondrial membrane
and when we looked at this iron sulfur
protein we found it in either a
completely on Khalif state or in a once
cleaved state as if the protein had not
folded correctly and had not undergone
the proper cleavage that enables it's
correct biogenesis so this was the first
of a monomeric protein where we saw
effects in this particular mutant we at
this point we rescued the mutant with a
yeast library so we put on a bank of
yeast clones and the gene the
rescued was sequenced by Ming Chang
during I believe it was summer 1988 and
at this point we knew that there was a
modesty heat inducible protein in inside
mitochondria they've been identified the
year before by Richard Hallberg working
in Iowa in tetrahymena and we had a
feeling that Hallberg was analyzing the
sequence of the corresponding homolog in
yeast with a view to doing further
experiments in that system so on a
Saturday afternoon in that summer Ming
Chang called up Richard Hallberg with
two men to see whether her sequence of
this gene would match the sequence that
he had of the homolog he was studying
well I had gone to JFK Airport to pick
up old rush because the two of us were
going to a Gordon conference on
mitochondria the next day and my son
came with us and it was many hours but
we got back to the to our little beach
house at around 6 o'clock in the evening
and there's Ming Chang and the rest of
the lab standing in our front yard and
Ming's just jumping up and down holding
a sequencing gel saying it's a dead
match it's a dead match and we said well
what's the dead match she said I called
up Hallberg our protein corresponds to
this ring assembly then he's studying
and so that two and two came together in
a really amazing moment and we had a
wonderful evening of celebration but
basically what it amounted to was what
we then called heat shock protein 60
collectively with Richard and and Ulrich
and Walter and everybody this modestly
heat inducible protein was actually
assisting the folding of all these
proteins being imported into the
mitochondrial matrix and in fact however
HSP 60 is essential at all temperatures
so its assistance to polypeptide chain
folding is required under normal
conditions which embody often relatively
high temperatures and very high solute
concentrations in the mitochondrial
matrix
ergo this machine is essential under all
conditions
now shortly after this ulrich carried
out a beautiful experiment with yokomo
sermon where they analyzed another
monomeric protein dihydrofolate
reductase and what they could see was
that when they put a signal peptide on
dhfr to make it go into mitochondria
much as in the shots experiments letting
it go into mitochondria it became
associated with this complex with this
ring assembly that Hallberg had first
identified the HSV 60 complex as long as
ATP was relatively deprived from
mitochondria if they added ATP back to
this system they now saw a dhfr depart
from this complex and appear as a native
folded protein while the protein I
should say was associated with HSV 60 it
seemed to be non-native very protease
susceptible recognizable by antibodies
that specifically saw non-native forms
of dhfr and so these experiments really
with risky iron-sulfur protein with dhfr
convinced us that HSV 60 was some sort
of a folding machine in the
mitochondrial matrix and of course
there's some generality to this because
we saw the sequence of HSV 60 we knew
already that it was going to be
homologous and is homologous to the grow
L protein in the bacterial cytoplasm
essential in that context and had been
shown to be involved or had been
implicated early as being involved with
lambda phage at assembly now this idea
had to move to lambda phage protein
folding there was also a protein inside
of chloroplasts called the Rubisco
binding protein identified by john ellis
as being required for assembly of
Rubisco which is a co to fix a fixing
enzyme in fact the most abundant protein
in the biosphere this now had to go to
the level of thinking that Rubisco
binding protein was actually mediating
protein folding of Rubisco subunits and
finally shortly thereafter working
together or ish and I with Jonathan
Trent identified a heat shock protein in
thermophilic arca bacteria that we
called thermophilic
factor 55 another double ring assembly
that is highly induced when you take
these normally heat-loving bacteria and
take them to an even higher temperature
that turns out to look just like a
chaperonin and it also could turn over a
teepee and behave just like these other
ring assemblies and in fact when we
analyze this subunit we found a homology
to a protein in the eukaryotic cytosol
called TCP one or CCT for short this
being the eukaryotic Sam ember of the
eukaryotic cytosolic chaperone and one
subunit of the eight subunit rings that
comprised that chaperon an essential for
folding actin tubulin bethe propeller
proteins and many other proteins so the
generality of these ring assemblies and
mediating protein folding to the native
state seem to be getting established
and so finally mechanistically twenty
years later we understand at least how
the bacterial chaperonin system works in
pretty good detail now with much
biochemistry x-ray crystallography NMR
studies and a lot of e/m conducted on
this particular machinery the Gro yell
machine and it's cooperating component
grow yes and the bottom line in terms of
mechanism is that an open ring of Gro
yell with all this hydrophobic surface
specifically binds non-native proteins
through their exposure of hydrophobic
surface that will be buried to the
interior in the native state thus Gro
yell specifically recognizes non-native
proteins and once it's bound to protein
when grow yes now encapsulate s' the
same ring that's bound by poly pipe by
poly peptide the polypeptide is released
into this hydrophilic folding chamber
all this blue here signifies
electrostatic residues and the
polypeptide now folds in isolation in a
sequestered environment where it simply
can't aggregate with any other protein
and it basically uses an FinCEN's
principles its primary structure to find
its way to the native state without the
fear of aggregation or going off pathway
and being lost
so in general molecular chaperones if
one wants to talk about all the classes
of these components they basically
recognize exposed hydrophobic surfaces
that are proffered when a protein miss
folds or during biogenesis and the idea
of the chaperone is to bind these
surfaces and prevent them from associate
self associating with each other in
multi molecular aggregates the idea of
all of the chaperones is to prevent
aggregation by binding these surfaces in
various geometric contexts the
remarkable thing about the chaperonins
however that's really unique is that
they use nucleotide to release the
polypeptide into a sequestered folding
chamber where the polypeptide really has
no chance of aggregation and has a
chance to fold using its own primary
structure to the native state one of
nature's really most beautiful machines
used for this final step of information
transfer so thanks very much for
listening to this lecture I hope you
enjoyed it thank you